[Music]  what happened I had a heart attack I had  to give a transplant is it feeling you  different  can't you tell it's someone else's I  just want everything to go back to the  way it was before it's just so weird  that someone had to die in order for me  to live Nuria French thank you both  your daughter she saved Sasha's life I  can't even begin imagining what you all  had been going through I just want you  to know that we're gonna do everything  we can to keep her memory alive Nancy  and I have endowed a scholarship in  Becky's name we want to offer the  scholarship to Sasha watch out for that  family you've seen things things that  she saw  this is scooting here Sasha  [Music]  I think that one day we're gonna look  back and realize that's this whole heart  attack thing was the best thing that  ever happen to you  [Music]  [Music]